The Asakusa Sensoji Temple in Tokyo finally stands before them...
...after two and a half years of waiting.
We've talked about coming since before COVID.
It was a dream of ours.
Even before getting jobs and stuff, it was just a dream.
And now we're here.
These university exchange students are also excited to be here.
I mean, when I was signing up for this program,...
...I was, like, constantly told that it might not happen.
Right?
So now that I'm finally here, I feel amazing.
However, it isn't the foreign tourist who had it the worst.
Harimacho is a guide.
The pandemic has had a strong impact on his business.
There was a time when he was peaking and there would be no one.
Decrease was crazy.
It was one tenth of what it used to be.
Nobody was coming.
In addition to the reopening of the country,...
...there's also the fall of the Japanese yen,...
...which is really good news for tourists.
Look here at the menu on the street.
This full meal costs only 1,000 yen, which is 7 euros or 7 dollars,...
...and chefs are very well aware of this.
I'll charge my customer the same.
As for my income, when foreigners are able to come to the country smoothly,...
...I'm expecting it to double.
Just before the pandemic, 31 million tourists visited Japan in 2019,...
...a historic record for the country.
After two and a half years of travel restrictions,...
...the nation hopes to revive this trend as soon as possible.